true but I'll take it
yes Get Closer Closer Closer
happy Monday everyone
so far over 2 million bucks has been
raised for Daniel Penny's defense
[Music]
to save a penny sounds like a typical
Democrat social program
is good news
still is it a match for the mob the mob
that disrupted subway service and
started brawls over the death of a
violent mentally ill homeless man see
they Thrive off violent extortion
lurking and waiting to pounce like a
lunatic on the F train and always adored
by the media and even though this dead
guy was a menace better at impersonating
Michael Myers than Michael Jackson
they're gonna reshape that narrative so
he's a martyr and the marina bad guy and
race will play the starring role even
though it was a bona fide Rainbow
Coalition teaming up to protect innocent
passengers from a raging lunatic but to
morons and race baiters that could only
mean one thing white supremacy which
means if the case doesn't go their way
prepare for the apocalypse on your
streets that's the extortion Neely was a
violent mess with serious mental issues
I see him every day usually outside CNN
headquarters
but if you ask the media he was a
talented Entertainer which is like
saying John Wayne Gacy was a clown
he was now mental illness can make you a
victim but also a victimizer and in
Neely's case there's a good chance when
he punched a few senior citizens he did
it because he felt like it oh there was
help out there for him for sure billions
in Social programs but what happened
there it's a scam called rent seeking
the practice of manipulating public
policy to increase profits if
homelessness actually gets better the
profits shrink so you got to keep that
problem alive it's really how the
Democratic party exists keep people
living at subsistence level and they
will have to rely on us forever after 42
priors Neely should have been locked up
but New York has a 180 strikes and
you're still not outlaw
so he roamed loose and because of left
sees dollar signs in sorrow they prefer
to unload these Maniacs on the rolling
Asylum called the subway a mode of
Transport these would never be caught
dead on
pun intended
Neely was on nyc's list of the top 50
people in dire need of help yeah the
government makes lists of people they
aren't helping isn't that the phone book
but the homeless service industry is
indeed an industry de Blasio threw a
billion to thrive NYC with his wife as
the boss Yepi hired the most qualified
person he was married to
and surprised it got worse and why
because the money flows up and not down
nothing was thriving but salaries they
threw another 240 million next fiscal
year to the Department of homeless
services and of course things got worse
so you had more homeless criminals
roaming Transit no one wants to mess
with them but they will mess with you
surely that's where Penny and others
step in New Yorkers are supposed to look
out for each other not look away but do
that and you'll be looking for a lawyer
Bragg charged him and City Hall must
have known so brag and the mayor bent
over for a few performance protesters
and they were indeed performers the
subway the subway event had to be staged
because there's no way those kids jump
onto a live Subway track and stay there
without knowing the train wouldn't turn
them into ground chuck
I mean they're zombies but they're not
literal zombies Maybe I'm Wrong
the protesters also needed police to be
involved because no cops were present
when Neely died so they needed conflict
on the streets between protesters and
cops a narrative the media always
Embraces and so the jury will hear that
story AOC and others will push the
lynching narrative as received wisdom
she wants to pull the lever for the
electric chair like it's a beer tap
but they run into a problem real people
who take the subway and anybody else who
just wants to get through their day with
a minimum of hassle we have to fight
this we have to support Daniel Penny not
against Jordan Neely but against the
Alvin Braggs and the aocs of the world
and also the old wretched dividers who
tear us apart by telling us that after
all racism has long torn us apart
racism has long torn us apart the most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy I'm not
saying this because I'm in a black hpcu
I stay wherever I go though you said it
because you were there you bozo
so how does that help blacks or whites
it's not meant to see dividing people
just makes them easier to conquer which
helps the rent-seeking crew Crooks who
make money off maintaining racial Strife
Joe's telling black grads they're
entering a world faced with invisible
white devils
and that's a lie you call white people
the devil and you're half right but it's
the half blacks keep voting for even
when Lucifer himself comes to your
graduation and lies to your face
[Applause]
she puts the war in wardrobe Farmer
State Department spokeswoman and founder
of Polaris Asos
he takes his prune juice shaken Notch
bird former CIA operative Mike Baker
she's got more fake hair than a
dollhouse daycare Fox News contributor
cat Tim
his biceps day takes two weeks my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
thank you
Mike it is true you're like the James
Bond for The Villages
I'm very popular at The Villages you
really are I'm sure you did you walk
down there are your clothes are clawed
off sometimes I just I'll hang outside
of Costco signing autographs yeah I've
got a certain demographic all right so
what's your solution here besides moving
to Idaho where you live
um I you know how the media is framing
this are we just heading for another
huge riot in like seven months yeah well
yeah just let it heat up a little bit
more out there on the streets I I it's
really it's such a sad tragic situation
right I mean this is again one of those
no win nobody wins here at all Jordan
nearly shouldn't have died Daniel Penny
didn't mean to kill him
reasonable people can agree to those
things right but the problem is that the
city New York City does almost nothing
for the mental health issues of a vast
number of people out on the streets much
less the homeless as you pointed out so
you know it's I can't really speak to
that what I can speak to is the fact
that President Biden uh has just lost
the plot right I like to always you
should always say good things about
people you should give them credit where
they do but there's something about
President Biden his inability to push
back against the really hard base that
he's pandering to for him to go to a
historically black college and say I'm
not pandering yeah is absurd of course
he's pandering and he does it constantly
and it's nothing but divisive and he
then wants to talk about how he's a
unifier so I I'm really done with his
position the problem is he appears to be
heading towards 2024 and we're going to
be talking about him for a while yet
yeah what do you think Morgan what's
worse him basically again saying white
supremacy is the number one domestic
threat which isn't true or how the media
is shaping this case into something that
will ultimately explode on the streets
they're both bad I do think that the
media is not winning on this one I'm
trying to turn it into trying to turn it
into a race controversy because enough
people sort of believe what Mike just
said that it was a terrible tragedy
um and that's why this Marine is raised
over I think over two million dollars
now online to come to his defense
um and so I don't know that the media
can get away with it like it's sort of
like rinse and repeat the news cycles
that they do and I think it's hard to
perpetrate that listen I like Mike have
spent my career worrying about threats
to the Homeland and things that could
you know that be dangerous to all of us
things that could attack us uh and I
spent my whole career doing that and I'm
old enough to remember the Chinese spy
balloon right I'm old enough to remember
the fall of Kabul or the record number
of terrorists that are apprehended at
our border that are on the terrorist
watch list these are the things that I
worry about every day as a national
security professional and so the
president is just flat out lying and
pandering uh to an audience that and
dividing us cat what have you to say
about his his commencement address or
you may speak about the subway if you
wish
I do kind of want to talk about the
Subway because I think that something
people aren't talking enough about is
the fact that there were people on the
subway calling 9-1-1 before this
confrontation even happened and people
who are watching who have not spent time
on the New York subway the bar is so
high for what would actually make you
call 911 right that's a great Point like
people who've not been here might not
realize what you can expect to see on a
normal day a Subway and be like well
that again there there's another penis
I wouldn't call the cops if a guy was
exposing himself or pooping I would just
scope that but I gotta live with that I
saw a woman once take her pants off take
and then go back on and just lay down
and I was like well that's I I saw a guy
I saw a guy one time bandaging a bloody
like gushing bloody Toe with a wad of 20
bills I'm like that's definitely a guy
who does crimes no that was Larry and I
just got out you know you just get up
and you go about your day and it's not
good I'm not saying it's a good thing
and it has gotten a lot worse than it
was but the things that you accept
without calling 9-1-1 because it's just
unfortunately normal disgusting life on
the subway
there's something to be said for the
fact that this was different because
that is a different action for New
Yorkers to be right they were called
before that this nobody ever calls no no
one does Tyrus thoughts uh I have two
thoughts on this one first of all this
I love your monologue and thank you for
having the balls to say it number one
but you you always it's just your you
really look for the best in some of the
worst people bragging them weren't
bullied into this they saw the
opportunity absolutely because they got
an opportunity we wouldn't even be
having this conversation if if the
Marine wasn't white let's just say it
period and once they saw that it was a
white man who had the who had the rear
naked choke on a black man that's when
the mom said gotcha and they came out
they're not saying anything are the two
that were holding hands and holding in
the ground are those co-conspirators you
know they're going to be arrested you
know or everyone else that was in the in
the in the subway in the lunch box yeah
that's why I don't ride a Subway I don't
fit yeah you know what I'm saying I
don't so all the people in that hot
lunch box that were terrified and Afraid
are they all gonna be arrested too
because they didn't do anything
again what they were hoping for and what
they want is they want another George
Floyd moment the problem was he's just
ordinary white citizen who used to be a
marine if he was a police officer they
would really get their fundraising going
and that's what they're really upset
about but the timing on this again this
happens
it's national news now everyone wants to
talk about it
we're not talking about Hunter anymore
yeah not talking about in place debt
ceiling anymore we're not talking about
China anymore
we're talking about this and then lo and
behold the president's speech is about
what what is the most dangerous thing in
this country apparently white men yes so
you got the president saying this and
this poor bastard who was just finally
did something you know how many videos
we've seen on the subway where a woman's
crying for help the worst one I saw was
a man grabbed her hair made her sit with
him and she's screaming for help nobody
no no no Whispering please help me
please help me no one did anything the
brother that stood over and beat the
Asian woman to damn near death in the
corner no one did anything finally a
group of men men are back and came and
did something is it unfortunate he lost
his life yes but he took that risk when
he decided to attack threaten and do
that those type of things I just think
it's I love the speeches when everyone
comes out the where were the family when
this poor man was walking the Subways
exactly to be arrested 40 times
I will say I mean it's a it's a it's a
it's really is a not talked about as cat
said in terms of if you just took that
subway car that one car well where
Daniel Penny was and the idea that he
was doing it for racist motives you
think he actually stood around and look
says okay I'm gonna go protect just the
white people in this no or else so I'm
going to get into this car yeah because
I plan on killing this person the odds
of that happening are very low and I'm a
scientist okay we got to move on up next
Kia in Hyundai need legal advisors
because their cars lack immobilizers wow
that's a tease hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else